alright step in between the lines you
know my competitive niches it's going to
take over anything can you starve
introduce yourself without laughing
[Applause]
Margit Barrett I'm a freshman I play for
do nice to meet you I'm a Robert here
goes all right yeah why am i cute I'm
doing a story on RJ Barrett oh no way to
report oh do you yeah you guys know each
other
he's my godson Coach K
hey Anu recruits yeah I wish welcome
have a seat you know obviously RJ's
family to me
yes I've watched him from a baby become
you know this world-class prospect what
was it the use on him in the recruiting
process that made you think this is a
guy got to have yeah there are two main
things one the obvious talent and the
fact that he defies position he's so
talented and he can play everywhere
really the second thing is his
competitiveness he's really the ultimate
winner I hate losing losing is one of
the worst feelings in the world
I feel like that you know desire to win
that competitive nature when you have
that you you really do whatever the team
needs to do to win so you know that's
that's one of the things that I love
about myself thing I love my guys is
that we're we're all happy for each
other no matter you know who gets
drafted we're you know we're really
happy for each other the relationship of
RJ and Zion is one of the incredible
things I've encountered they have
morphed into this Brotherhood
I was ayat and I are really close to
we're always together the night before
every home game design and I go get a
haircut he gets the little Z in his head
and now I get my two lines and then on
the day of the game i videotape him
driving and you know we're just singing
along to songs and I post that for you
know as a reminder everybody you know
it's game day and that we're locked in
and we're ready what's it like out here
on game I've never been to Cameron and
it's just amazing the Cameron Crazies
are you know the best fans in the world
our student section is wild and I like
that it's it's smaller so that you can
have that interaction with the fans
yeah it's great the energy must be crazy
[Applause]
during March Madness is when I would
always tune in and always see you know
these different games and I remember
always seeing Duke in the mix that just
gave me inspiration that I knew I'm
gonna have to go to cause RJ committed
early so I tried to get to know him more
before he got here and then you get to
meet his family and you say oh my god
you know this is like perfect I'm
fortunate to have a dad that has played
at a high level in basketball and
growing up he would teach me more
advanced things than maybe you know
other people were getting at at a
younger age when do you think RJ
develops like a work ethic 7th grade you
know he was playing soccer - right and
so he comes to me one day says you know
daddy I don't want to miss any more
basketball tournaments I don't want to
play soccer more you tell your kids to
reach for the you know but when they
actually tell you that they want to like
what do you do you know you don't want
to crush my sphere by telling me is
gonna be really hard so each other just
helped me plan out you know certain
things that I would have to do and how
hard I would have to work to achieve
those things you know some of my
favorite players that I like to you know
pick different stuff from I love Kobe's
mentality
I love James Harden's scoring ability
but also his playmaking ability now I
loved the way LeBron plays the game
unselfish and you know he's the best
player in the world those you know three
guys have been you know what I've been
you know looking for growing up one of
the things that I see with you know
Coach K is he's consistent you know
every day he comes the same way he's
gonna coach this hard the same way every
day you know if you're messing up he's
gonna tell you like just knowing that
from from him it makes us want to play
even harder you know we don't want to
disappoint him because of you know how
much we respect him and how much he
shows us respect I think it all goes
back to family I'm telling it they're
they're rock solid they're rock solid
you hit it
I think that's the great thing like
every time you speak to him so relatable
personable funny I did not know he was
that funny he's you know he can relate
to us 18 year olds only he's making us
laugh like the what is this how do you
know anything about our era he has Apple
watch the newest iPhone all the newest
shoes were like okay coach nothing I
mean he's got one of the all-time best
mothers incredibly loving person loving
and that's he has that and I think
that's why he's so secure and humble I
grew up in a sports family so I'm used
to you know this one is gone this one is
over here and but we always support each
other and we're very close family so all
the advice that we got everyone said be
either be around as much as you can for
balance you know so we tried to do that
and how often do you get over you know
whenever you have free time or you know
if - Friday or Saturday and Sunday just
hum just relax you know being here in
the place where you know sometimes I get
to be by myself or just be with my
families it's really huge
my family and you know my coaches and my
teammates was was just great you know to
help me to stay consistent and just be
true to myself I I've loved coaching
this group and I've loved coaching RJ a
big thing we're going through with him
right now
is empowerment and then I find out the
day we play Syracuse that RJ was texting
Alex about you're gonna be good
well you're in a corner you're spacing
the student we got you 100% both weight
and knocking down today yeah appreciate
it I mean one of my teammates texted me
today that he had my back 100% and it
made me feel even more confident shout
out to RJ berry every one of Alex's
three-point shots was an assist from RJ
it's one of those things that he's
learning right now which is so cool RJ
is gonna be an all-star he's gonna be
he's gonna be one of the best players in
in the NBA right away you know right
away coming here I just felt that
playing with other great players it
would help me because when you get to
the NBA everybody's a good player so
that would just you know give me some
practice before I get to the NBA you
like to smile
[Music]
what's up you guys it's Taylor Brooks
with bleach to report make sure that you
subscribe for more video content